الاستاذ محمود الافندي المحلى السياسي
والاستاذ في الاكاديميه الروسيه اهلا بك
استاذ محمود علي نبدا معك من ملفي باخ موت
هذه المدينه التي قلت روسيا انها ان
سقوطها سيكون وشيك ليست روسيا فقط لكن
هناك ايضا الامين العام لحرفي شمال
الاطلسي بالتالي هل هي مساله ايام او
ساعات فقط لسقوطها بالنسبه لموسكو
اول شيء
فعليا يعني نرى ان الحرب الحديثه روسيا
تعتمد على اسلوب ما يسمى المحاصره وليس
الاقتحام يعني اول شيء المحاصره لمنع خطوط
الامداد
وقوات الامداد وان كان عسكريه او حتى
اخراج الجرحى والدعم العسكري ان كان
البشري وكان عدد العسكري فعليا تعتمد على
واستطعت روسيا عند تغلق الحصار عند خط جسر
وهي مدينه مهمه تقريبا انقطع كل ما يسمى
خطوط الامداد وخصوصا ان فعليا اصبحت فقط
الطرق ما يسمى البريه او اللي فيها غابات
مكثفه بالاضافه انها وعره الان بسبب ذوبان
الثلوج وتصبح مطيده يعني طين كثيف لا
يستطيع الاليات ان تخرجها فقط يستطيع
الاشخاص الهروب من هذه المنطقه ففعليا ليس
هناك اي دعم عسكريه يستطيع ان يدخل الان
فعليا ان يدخل الى
لذلك القوات الروسيه لا تستعجل امر لمنع
الخسائر من صف الروسي لانه دائما المهاجم
يحصل كثيرا اكثر من المدافع ففعلا روسيا
تحاول
ربما من منطلق ان قائد مجموعه فاغنر ربما
او اشتكى قله الذخائر او ارسال موسكو
للذخائر لقواته هل ربما يؤثر ذلك على
القوات على الارض
فعليا فعليا هو هناك تنافس يعني خلينا
نكون واقعي هناك تنافس عسكري ما بين قوات
فاجنر كشركه خاصه ووزاره الدفاع والجيش
الروسي ففعليا كله يريد الولاء لروسيا او
للرئيس بوتين يعني نوعا ما
الدفاع يعني تحاول ان تؤخر الذخيره ولا
تقطعها يعني كان في تاخير من الذخيره فهمه
بانه ليس عسكريا وانه مدنيا فهمه وكان
نوعا من التحديات لذلك اطلق صراخين من قبل
قناه تيليجرام ان وزاره الدفاع تتحدى ولكن
فعليا يعني نقول هناك نوع من منافسه
ولكن
يعني لا ربما تغيير جدري في التوجه الروسي
في هذه الحرب لكن ربما بالنظر الى عديد من
المتغيرات هل هناك ربما دراسه انيه
للاستراتيجيه السياسيه وايضا العسكريه في
سياق هذه الحرب
فعليا روسيا اتخذت قرار منذ فعاليه من
حوالي اربعه اشهر هي يعني التقدم ببطء
للحفاظ على القوات العسكريه وانها جعلتها
حرب استنزاف يعني استسلمت حرب الاستنزاف
وفهمت ان عليها الان
ما يسمى تحقيق اهدافه العسكريه قتل ما
يسمى الجيش الاوكراني يعني انهاء الجيش
الاوكراني كعتاد بشري وليس عتاد معدات
عسكريه وهذا الان ما تقوم فيه روسيا
العماره ان هناك يعني خسارات مدينه هائله
للجيش الاوكراني وكذلك الان في مدينه لذلك
رؤوس الان تعتمد استراتيجيه القضاء على
الجيش الاوكراني حتى لا يعني حتى لو قدمت
اسلحه لا يستطيع يعني ليس هناك اي دول من
انواع القوات المدربه يمكن ان تحارب روسيا
يمكن لاوكرانيا وقتها ان تستسلم فروسيا
الان يعني حتى اعترف الرئيس عده مرات الان
يقول ان القتال اصبح حتى اخر اوكرانيا
يعني ما اخر اوكرانيا كمواطن ولكن كعسكر
او مجند او محمود بخصوص زياره وزير
الخارجيه السعودي الى موسكو هي زياره
سياسيه وقت اقتصاديه بامتياز بالتالي هل
يمتزج ربما الشقان في هذه الزياره
طبعا هذا شيء اكيد لانه نرى اصول محمد بن
سلمان الى درفه السلطه تقريبا في السعوديه
اصبحت العلاقات الروسيه السعودي تطور بشكل
هائل وخصوصا بالسعوديه الان تقوم بدور جيد
في الاوبك لوس في استقرار اسعار الطاقه
بنفس الوقت تقوم بالحياد السياسي الكامل
الحرب الاوكرانيه وهي تساعد على التسويه
السياسيه وخصوصا التبادل الاسرى يتم فقط
عن طريق الامارات العربيه المتحده
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه وبعض الشيء
تركيا فهذا امر جيد بالنسبه روسيا انه
هناك خطوط اتصال موثوق بها اهم شيء ثقه
دائما بتبادل اسره هناك ثقه فالثقه الان
كامله بين السعوديه وروسيا في هذا الموضوع
بالاضافه الى موضوعات اقليميه اخرى وخصوصا
تحاول روسيا ادخال السعودي او ارجاع سوريا
للجامعه العربيه عن طريق السعوديه بما
يسمى استقرار المنطقه وخروج نوعا ما سوريا
من النفوس الايراني عن طريق دخول الدول
العربيه ومساعده سوريا لعرض بناء وخصوصا
بعد الزلزال شكرا لك استاذ محمود الافندي
المحلل السياسي واستاذ في الاكاديميه
الروسيه حدثنا من موسكو شكرا